Trump is based
what his defense is in this case,
much of it around the idea
that in his view,
Eugene Carroll is not his type.
Putting aside
obviously the fact that rape
and sexual assault
is about power,
not necessarily attraction.
That claim
seemed to be undermined by himself
during the deposition.
Yeah, there's
this moment in the deposition
where Trump is being shown
a photo of him and his
then wife, Ivana Trump,
at some gala
with Jean Carroll
and her then husband John Johnson.
So Trump is looking
at this black and white photo,
which we have seen before,
and he's being presented
like this is Eugene Carroll
back at the time period.
This is just a few years
before the alleged assault.
She's being shown this photo.
Take a listen to his reaction to it.
I don't even know who the woman.
Let's see. I don't know who.
It's Marla.
You say marbles in the photo.
That's Marla.
Yeah, it's my wife.
Which one
are you pointing something out here?
I said
because you just pointed to his voice.
Who is it? Cruz's point.
Your wife.
And the person of the woman
on the right is your then wife.
I don't know if this was the picture
I assume that's John Johnson. Is that.
That's correct.
Because it's very blurry
there, Jake, as you see there,
that Trump is confusing.
Jean Carroll
from the early nineties
with his second wife, Marla Maples.
And later in the deposition,
he is asked by Carol's attorney.
Are all of your wives your type?
And Trump says, yes, that they are.
So this is something that Carol's team
wants to use
to undercut his argument
that she wasn't his type
and that
that statement was a lie,
which goes toward
one of the defamation claims
in this case.
You know, it's interesting
because Trump, as you said,
has waived his right to testify.
He's not attended any of the civil trial
and he's not required to.
But this will be the only words
that the jury will see, the words
and Trump's reaction to the questions
as they consider this case.
And they could get it
as early as Tuesday, Jake. Yeah.
And the jury will also see,
of course, that the photograph
is not blurry at all.
Kara Scannell, thank you so much.
Here to break down
what we learned from the Trump
deposition tapes are two former
federal prosecutors,
Renato Mariani and Jennifer Rogers, who's
also a CNN legal analyst.
Let me start with you. So
let's
start with where Kerry just dropped it.
Trump said he couldn't possibly
have sexual assault
on Egypt, Carol,
because and I'm quoting him
now, she's not my type.
And yet here we have him
mistaking a picture of Jean Carroll
with his ex-wife, Marla Maples,
who obviously is his type
Yeah, it's a huge blunder on his part.
I mean, listen, of course,
as you mentioned
before, Jake,
rape is not really
about sexual attraction.
It's about power and domination
and control
but even assuming for a second
that's his defense,
you know,
you might expect his defense to be
of course, I didn't do it.
But secondarily,
you might expect someone in this scenario
to say
not she's not my type,
but instead something along the lines of
I would never do this.
My character is too good.
Let me bring forward
dozens of witnesses
to tell you about how this is not
the sort of thing I would ever do.
He can't do that here. Why?
Because that is not his character.
He couldn't find any witnesses
to say that.
And in fact, quite the opposite.
There would be then dozens of witnesses
on the other side
to testify to the contrary.
So he's left with this
ridiculous defense of, gee,
I don't really find her attractive.
And now that's
not even really available to him either.
Because he's mucked it up with this photo
and we're not.
The jury did hear from Agent Carroll
and another woman
who accuse him of sexual assault.
Trump's lawyers presented
no witnesses of their own.
What do you make of this strategy?
Well, you can see why,
Jake, after watching some of these clips,
why they might not want him on the stand.
But it comes at a very serious risk.
You know,
Jennifer just mentioned a moment ago,
and I think she's right
that the defense you'd expect from
a defendant here would be of
I would never do this.
This is awful.
I'm just so outraged and and
and concerned
that I am being accused of committing
a very serious violent crime.
But instead, I think by,
you know,
not only is
he not appearing to testify in person,
which means the jury is really
never going to have
any sort of emotional connection there
with him.
But, you know,
and be able to really assess that.
But he sat there during the proceedings
that really,
I think, is giving the jury
the impression
that he's not taking this seriously.
And so
if they unless they totally disbelieve
everything Carol said
and the other witnesses,
I think that really Trump
and his team are putting
themselves in a position
to lose this case.
All right.
Let me get back
to one of the most shocking quotes
from from this deposition.
Trump is heard on the Access
Hollywood tape back from 2005
2006, bragging
about how if you're a star,
you can grab women by their genitals
whether they want it or not.
During the deposition,
he was asked about it.
He said that stars can do that.
And then he
says unfortunately or fortunately
or fortunately, I mean, doesn't
that lend credence to the idea
that he thinks
that sometimes it's a good thing
that stars can get away
with grabbing women by their genitals,
whether they want them or not,
Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
I'm sorry. Jennifer.
Jennifer, if you could do it. I'm sorry.
Jennifer.
Yeah,
I mean,
this is another
missed opportunity for him.
If I'm Trump's lawyer,
I'm telling him to keep going with this,
you know, locker room defense.
It was just talk.
I really don't mean it.
That's a terrible thing.
Instead, he doubles down and says,
yeah, sure,
stars can do whatever they want,
you know, for a million years now.
So, you know, he is a terrible
witness is why we'll never see him
on the stand voluntarily.
But even these clips demonstrate
how he doesn't listen to his lawyers.
And to the extent
he has
any sort of hope of appearing
to have a decent shot
at undercutting each.
In Carroll's case,
he just flubs it every time.
And Renato,
unlike in a criminal case, it's
a civil matter.
So it just Agent
Carroll just needs to succeed
and prevail
by a preponderance of the evidence.
It does not have to be beyond
all reasonable doubt.
That's something important
for people to remember here.
The standard is lower for a civil case
That's right.
She only
has approved
by essentially 51% of the evidence.
And of course, the evidence is all on her
side of the ledger here
is really going to be a lot of argument.
I would say on the defense side,
I do think that she has put herself
in a position
to potentially get
a verdict in her favor,
which is really something
because there were challenges
in her case.
Obviously, this happened long ago.
There are you know,
there was no physical evidence.
So definitely some challenges there.
And I think Trump's team
and his own decisions
are including
some of the very problematic,
disturbing testimony we just heard,
I think contributes to that.
Yeah, not a slam dunk by any means.
And who knows what's going to happen,
but seems like Mr.
Trump helped her a lot today.
Jennifer Rogers, Renato
Mariani, thank you.